la sixième armée allemande en cercle à
stalingrad est soumise depuis deux mois
des attaques incessantes les vivres
commencent à manquer et le nombre de
pertes humaines est à la
l'artillerie soviétique pilote à la
sable mots les positions allemandes et
les tentes et dans le cadre détruisent
les derniers panzers allemands
malgré les promesses de hermann goering
la luftwaffe s'approcha mais assez pour
livrer le ravitaillement nécessaire et
claire ordonne aux forces du maréchal
von manstein de sauver la sixième armée
mais cet ordre est vouée à l'échec
le général von par lowe's se rend à
l'évidence et seront anéantis s'il ne se
vendent pas
la chance a tourné sur le fond de baisse
la conférence de casablanca après la
victoire des alliés en afrique du nord
les américains et les britanniques
doivent se mettre d'accord sur la
stratégie à adopter
roosevelt et churchill se rencontrent à
casablanca le 14 janvier 1943
les américains veulent traverser la
manche pour attaquer l'allemagne alors
que churchill déclare qu'il faut
consolider la méditerranée roosevelt
n'est pas d'accord avec ses chefs
militaires et soutient les britanniques
néanmoins il n'est pas question de
débarquer plus de soldats dans la région
méditerranéenne
les renforts iront en angleterre afin de
préparer l'invasion de la france en 1944
la bataille de leningrad le siège de
leningrad dure environ 900 jours de
septembre 41 à janvier 44
les allemands ont coupé l'eau et
l'électricité
ils soumettent la population à des
attaques aériennes et d'artv incessantes
les trois millions d'habitants sont en
train de mourir de faim et le froid mais
la population refuse de se rendent et
met en place des usines de guerre local
et surtout une voie de ravitaillement la
route de la vie sur le lac ladoga qui
est gelé ce lien vital permet de
ravitailler la ville et donne la
possibilité à plus de 500 milles
personnes de s'échapper
la conférence de casablanca se termine
la conférence de casablanca entre
roosevelt et churchill débute le 14
janvier 43 et arrive à son terme le 24
janvier
roosevelt surprend ses propres chefs
militaires en acceptant de retarder d'un
an
l'invasion de la france à la demande de
churchill il échappe d'autant plus quand
il déclare qu'il n'acceptera qu'une
reddition sans condition de la part des
forces de l' axe cette décision a pour
but de rassurer l'union soviétique qui
doit maintenant attendre encore un an
avant qu'un second front ne soit mis en
place
elle ne cesse de demander ce deuxième
front depuis que la bataille de
stalingrad a commencé
les soviétiques prennent voronej on naît
le 8 janvier au beau milieu de l'hiver
russe et une partie de la sixième armée
allemande capitule à stalingrad l'armée
rouge tout à sa joie devant la victoire
se met à attaquer sur tous les points
faibles
100 kg mais quand pau stalingrad est
bonne
parcourez en deux
la ville est repris
les allemands sont nuls
une fois ce soviétiques font prisonnier
52 mille soldats allemands à voronej
elles sont à moins de 200 km de la ville
de course pour la plus grande valeur
d'autant de toute l'histoire a varié
les troupes allemandes capitule à
stalingrad la sixième armée du général
von pao luz est encerclée à stalingrad
depuis novembre 1942 elle est soumise à
de lourdes pertes
la luftwaffe n'arrivent pas à livrer du
ravitaillement
le maréchal eric von manstein abandonne
ses tentatives de sauvetage et le
maréchal joffre mènent une
contre-offensive contre les allemands en
déployant un grand nombre de tentes et
30 cadres tous ces événements vont
provoquer la première grande défaite
allemande sur le front de l'est
humilié faune pas au loudes capitule
devant le haut commandement soviétique
l'ironie c'est que peu de jours
auparavant adolf hitler avait promu
phone pas au loup ce car on lui avait
dit qu'aucun maréchal ne s'était jamais
rendu il est le premier
l'armée soviétique atteint la mer d'azov
et coupe la route au groupe a de l'armée
allemande
après la chute de stalingrad
il est important pour l'union soviétique
d'atteindre la mer l'accès le plus
proche est la pointe s de la mer noire à
azov à seulement 30 km à l'ouest de la
ville de rostov l'armée rouge rencontre
une ferme opposition en traversant la
vallée du don les allemands savent que
s'ils perdent ce secteur
les conséquences seront lourdes c'est le
chaos
les forces soviétiques athènes à sauf le
6 février 1940
le groupe a de l'armée allemande se
retrouve plus les cellules
donc
on a mieux paru
les américains sécurisé guadalcanal les
forces américaines débarquent à
guadalcanal dans les îles salomon le 7
août 42
mais les japonais résiste au nord de
l'île ils ne veulent pas abandonner la
base aérienne de henderson
chaque camp obtient des renforts on est
dans l'impasse durant six mois
les combats sont acharnés et les pertes
très élevé au début de l'année 43
il y à plus de 50 milles soldats
américains sur l'île et les américains
ont intensifié les attaques
le 4 février le quartier général de l'
empire japonais admet guadalcanal est
perdu ils commencent à évacuer le 8
février les américains contrôlent toute
l'île
rommel attaquent les forces américaines
en afrique du nord durant l'opération
torch les troupes alliées réussissent
leur débarquement en afrique du nord
le 16 février la viiie armée américaine
atteint la ligne m'arrête en tunisie le
maréchal rommel lance une offensive
l'opération morgen luft rommel veut
causer un maximum de pertes humaines et
provoquer la confusion chez les jeunes
soldats américains avec un peu de chance
il pourra détruire les bases de beaune
et constantine
les zinnias cas de coopération entre
rommel et le commandant des 10e et 21e
division de panzers le général von arx
moore en conséquence les forces de
l'action peu de chances d'arriver à leur
but
la viiie armée britannique prend
medenine tripoli est aux mains de la
viiie armée britannique et montgomery
poursuit son avancée vers la tunisie et
profite de sa position actuelle pour
faire diversion pendant que les
américains arrivent par l'ouest
le prochain obstacle des alliés est la
ville de medenine à 300 km à l'ouest de
tripoli
le penseur allemand sont obligés de se
retirer le 20 février 1943
les britanniques peuvent sécuriser la
ville rommel lancent une attaque sur
medenine mais ils essuient une lourde
défaite deux ans de combats incessants
ont eu raison du maréchal allemand
il rentre en allemagne épuisé et malade
les alliés reprennent le col de
kasserine la guerre en afrique du nord
penche en faveur des alliés pourtant le
maréchal rommel créé la surprise
il attaque la première division armée
des années les gars au col de kasserine
en tunisie les gi's inexpérimenté
reçoivent une correction très sévère et
ne sont pas aussi aguerri que les
combattants endurci de l'afrika korps
dirigée par le général von arx mine
après le départ de rommel les allemands
réussissent presque à percer les toc
avait formé les alliés néanmoins le 25
février 43 les troupes alliées arrive
pas reprendre l'important passage du col
de kasserine bataille navale sur la mer
de bismarck la mère de bismarck au nord
de la papouasie nouvelle guinée sera le
théâtre d'une nouvelle grande victoire
pour les alliés durant la guerre du
pacifique
le convoi de renforts japonais est
attaqué le 2 mars 43 par des vedettes
lance torpilles et l'aviation alliée
près de là et sur le golf de urnes leur
aide prend par surprise le commandant
japonais il durera jusqu'au 5 mars et
anéantira la flotte japonaise
la bataille de la mer de bismarck montre
à nouveau que la chance est en train de
changer de camp dans la guerre du
pacifique les forces japonaises sont à
bout la production industrielle n'est
pas aussi importante que celle des états
unis spitfire contre messerschmitt au
dessus de la manche
la confrontation entre les spitfire et
les messerschmitt 109 ne s'arrête pas
avec la bataille d'angleterre
elle se poursuit sur d'autres théâtres
de la guerre
les pilotes de la bataille d'angleterre
sont considérés comme des vétérans
malgré leur jeune âge pour la plupart
ils n'ont que 20 ans mais ils sont prêts
à se battre jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
même si la mort les guette à tout le
monde
le 3 mars 43 un escadron de spitfire de
la ra f est sur le chemin du retour il
rencontre un groupe de messages sont au
nord des îles anglo normandes
quatre allemands seront abattus durant
son combat aérien
il n'y aura aucune perte britannique
le général patton restaure la ligne de
front après l'offensive de rommel rommel
attaque les positions américaines en
tunisie et fait reculer les jeunes gi's
méreau mal est un homme malade et
fatigué il doit quitter l'afrique du
nord pour debout général george patton
lance une contre offensive contre
l'ennemi dirigé dorénavant par le
général von arx mines sont incompétents
mais pas aussi doué grenelle l'étang
grande normalement moins puissants que
les penseurs allemands prennent
davantage
non seulement ils sont plus nombreux
mais ils manquent pas de munitions ni
surtout de carburant et 17 mars 43
patton restaure la ligne de front des
avis
la viiie armée britannique attaque la
ligne de mareth en tunise l'étau autour
des forces de l' axe se resserre
après l'échec retentissant de la contre
offensive de rommel à medenine la viiie
armée de montgomery se rapproche des
défenses de la ligne de marier le 20
mars
montgomery lance l'offensive et envoie
un détachement dans le sud qui rend plus
vulnérables le flanc droit de la ligne
de marek
comme les allemands s'ils se précisent
sur deux fronts ils doivent s'aider de
plus ils ne peuvent obtenir des renforts
puisque la première armée américaine a
rouvert son offensive à l'ouest et les
rats du désert père cela ligne de marais
les vannes russes sauve les pilotes de
chasse dans la manche
les pilotes de chasse britanniques qui
rencontrent des ennuis soit en escortant
des bombardiers soit en patrouillant au
dessus de la manche sont souvent obligés
de faire un amerrissage forcé des
patrouilles sont constamment à la
recherche de survivants
quand ils sont localisés un hydravion de
la plupart des cas un val russe va les
récupérer
il faut tout tenter pour aider un
camarade en dépit des risques
on ne peut pas le laisser en perdition
il faut faire quelque chose
il faut dire la vérité
le sauvetage d'un pilote de chasse n'est
pas un acte désintéressé
à l'époque un spitfire neuf coûte
environ 2000
tandis que la formation d'un pilote est
évaluée à 20 mille livres les alliés
prennent tunis et bizerte au début du
mois de mai 43
les forces allemandes en afrique du nord
se replie progressivement vers bizerte
es tunis
tout a été pensé pour repousser les
allemands or de la tunisie et de
l'afrique du nord
l'offensive est lancée le symel par un
solide barrage d'artillerie
les affrontements sont violents 13
divisions allemandes se retrouve face à
19 du vision à lire les 130 penseurs
doivent riposter à 1300 tente d'allier
c'est inévitable le 7 mai bizerte est
une liste ombre et la guerre en afrique
du nord est presque terminée
la tunisie tombe les forces alliées en
cercle complètement les allemands à
bizerte es tunis dès le 7 mai 43 environ
258 soldats allemands et italiens se
rendent et le général en chef von arx
mines elle lui même capturé le 12 mai
nous représentants de toutes les forces
de l' axe en afrique du nord le maréchal
italien giovanni mais c'est capitule
devant les forces néo zélandaise le 13
mai le général alexander envoie le
télégramme suivant à churchill monsieur
je dois vous annoncer que la campagne de
tunisie est terminée l'ennemi a cessé de
résister nous contrôlons toute l'afrique
du nord
la guerre du désert est finie la
bataille des convois s'étend la pression
des u-boot sur les convois de
l'atlantique nord change radicalement
durant le premier semestre 1943 en
janvier la perte en tonnage est de 203
milton et en février elle s'élève à 359
mille tonnes en mars
on attend une perte gigantesque 627 1000
tonnes mais les chiffres pour avril et
mai sont respectivement de 245 milles et
165 mille tonnes en juin
cela se réduit à seulement dix huit
mille tonnes plusieurs raisons
expliquent ces revers de fortune que
subissent les allemands la plus
importante est une meilleure protection
aériennes des alliés qui acquièrent de
l'expérience après chaque poule joie
la bataille de koursk commence la
bataille de koursk la plus grande
bataille terrestre de l'histoire
commence le 5 juillet 1943 l'avancé
rapide de l'armée rouge vers l'ouest a
créé un saillant autour de la ville de
course
le haut commandement allemand décide
d'attaquer au nord et au sud
plus de deux millions d'hommes sont
engagés dans cette bataille ainsi que
trois mustang 18000 canaux des plus de
5000 avions adolf hitler n'a su avec
beaucoup d'attention et déclare notre
victoire à koursk illuminera le monde
entier
mais les russes sont au courant de leurs
plans et le prennent les devants les
allemands ne s'envoleront pas
les b 17 en opération dans le pacifique
les b 17 sont utilisés en grand nombre
pour la première fois dans le pacifique
durant la bataille de midway le
bombardement de la flotte japonaise est
un succès la forteresse volante inventé
dans les années 30 devient le bombardier
les plus efficaces de l'arsenal allié au
milieu de l'année 43 la dernière version
est employée en europe et dans le
pacifique
elle est de loin la mieux armée avec des
mitrailleuses de calibre 11 50 et peut
transporter plus de 17000 livre de boom
de plus elle a une autonomie de vol
impressionnant d'au moins cinq mille
cinq cents trimestre
d'autres ont suivi mais le b 17 est
resté une référence en matière de
bombardier
les allemands sont en difficulté au
saillan d'aurel
non seulement la bataille de koursk la
plus grande bataille terrestre de
l'histoire mais c'est aussi la plus
grande confrontation de blonde et elle
commence le 5 juillet car entre
si les allemands sont en difficulté au
salon dorel le 8 juillet 43
c'est tout simplement parce que l'armée
rouge est au courant de leurs projets
ceci est dû en grande partie à rudolph
rosseler et à ses collègues qui sont
connus sous le nom de lucie le réseau
suisse depuis des mois et livre des
informations sur l'armée allemande à
moscou qui s'est mis à les prendre au
sérieux comme le haut commandement de
l'armée rouge agit en connaissant la
stratégie allemande
il n'est pas étonnant que la bataille
penche en sa faveur
la sicile est envahi durant la matinée
du 9 juillet 43 une flotte parce malte
et fonce droit sur la sicile
elle transporte la 7e armée américaine
et la fameuse viiie armée britannique
après les victoires en tunisie il faut
mettre en place un deuxième front en
europe afin de réduire la pression sur
le front de l'est en union soviétique
les américains veulent envahir l'europe
en passant par la manche
mais les britanniques pensent qu envahir
la sicile serait plus judicieux
l'invasion débute le 10 juillet les
américains débarquent d'âge et là sur la
côte sud pendant que les britanniques
débarquent plus à l'est
le premier débarquement allié en europe
et d'une réussite
contre-offensive soviétique durant la
bataille de course
l'opération petite adèle offensives
allemandes visant à pousser l'armée
rouge hors du saillant dorel est un
désastre dès le départ
le 13 juillet 43 l'armée rouge lance une
gigantesque contre offensive
rien ne peut arrêter les russes le 23
juillet les allemands sont repoussés
hors du salon
les pertes allemandes sont considérables
en une seule journée
vingt-cinq mille hommes et plus de 200
fournisseurs sont mis hors de combat
la bataille de koursk va durer encore
quelques semaines mais l'issue est
inéluctable
mussolini tombe
benito mussolini né le 29 juillet 1883
créé le parti fasciste italien fashi dit
combattimento en mars 1919 le roi
emmanuel ii l'invite à former un
gouvernement de coalition
le 28 octobre 1922 quand les fascistes
menacent de marcher sur rome mussolini
qu'on surnomme le duce entraîne l'italie
dans la seconde guerre mondiale en juin
mais le pays n'est pas prêt et suit de
nombreuses défaites militaires
en conséquence lui seul le nez congédié
par le roi le 25 juillet 1943
réd de la ra f / en mode hambourg nord
de l'allemagne est bombardé par l'armée
de l'air américaine au plein jour 25
juillet 1943
les cibles principales sont le port et
les installations industrielles
au cours de la nuit du 25 juillet les
bombardiers de la ras s'attaque
également à la vire
le maréchal de l'armée de l'air soeur
arthur harris bombardier ariste tient à
démontrer ce qu'on peut faire avec du
matériel sophistiqué et une connaissance
des tactiques militaires
des historiens affirment que les raids
nocturnes de la ra f ne devait pas
bombardé des cibles précises mais avait
pour seul but de terroriser la
population civile
les forces soviétiques prennent aurel la
bataille de koursk débute le 5 juillet
1943 elle entrera dans les annales comme
la plus grande bataille terrestre de
l'histoire
le but de cette opération dont le nom de
code allemand est opération citadelle
est de reprendre le saillant dorel à
l'armure les allemands attaquent par le
nord et le sud pour couper les forces
principales des soviétiques et les
prendre en tenaille mais ils ne font
qu'une percée minime dans le saillant
d'aurel une gigantesque contre-offensive
de l'armée rouge repousse les allemands
hors du saillant 5 après d'intenses
combats
les villes de rennes et de belgorod sont
à nouveau aux mains des soviétiques
réd 2 b 17 / regensburg et schweinfurt
mais raid américain en plein jour sur
des cibles continental sont beaucoup
plus nombreux en 43 les règles contre
lusine de messerschmitt à regensburg
près de la frontière autrichienne et
contre la fabrique de roulements à bille
à chaud à une faute au sud de
l'allemagne sur les premières missions
de longue distance
les deux red doivent être lancés à dix
minutes d'intervalle mais les
bombardiers en route pour schweinfurt
prennent un retard de trois heures à
cause du brouillard
de plus les avions de chasse ne peuvent
pas les couvrir
en raison de la distance du vol les red
seront mis à mal par la luftwaffe
sur les 200 b 17 partis en mission 59
seront perdu la bataille de koursk se
termine la bataille de courses débutent
le 5 juillet 43 et sera connue comme la
plus grande bataille de temps de toute
l'histoire
les allemands réduisent le front en
union soviétique
ce qui leur permet de récupérer deux
armées d'hitler vous saisir l'occasion
pour effectuer à nouveau un gigantesque
en certainement néanmoins l'armée rouge
résiste aux allemands est clair suspens
l'opération puisque les américains et
les britanniques débarquent dans sicile
il doit envoyer du renfort en italie
cette offensive à l'est aura pour seul
résultat de redonner aux forces
soviétiques le contrôle total du secteur
les japonais évacués news georgia et
d'autres îles salomon les forces
japonaises et alliés se livrent d'âpres
combats pour les îles salomon qui sont
d'une grande importance stratégique
cependant les américains sont en train
de prendre le dessus 28 ans 43 et
japonais prennent la décision d'évacuer
news georgia et d'autres îles salomon
afin de consolider leurs positions à
bougainville d'un nouvel bretagne
il est important pour les japonais de
maintenir à cet endroit une puissante
force pour empêcher une attaque sur deux
fronts aux philippines
l'une en direction des îles gilbert à
l'est et l'autre partant de l'australie
au sud
montgomery franchi le détroit de messine
la 7e armée américaine et la viiie armée
britannique commandé respectivement par
patton et montgomery envahissent la
sicile le 10 juillet 1943 et prennent le
contrôle de l'île
six semaines plus tard les italiens
n'ont pas le choix du gouvernement
récemment formé par le maréchal badoglio
fait savoir par des voies diplomatiques
qu'il veut négocier le 3 septembre 43 un
cours armistice a signé dans un champ
d'oliviers près de syracuse en sicile
le moment est approprié pour la viiie
armée britannique
elle peut franchir le détroit de messine
pour atteindre le sud de l'italie
les forces alliées débarquent à salerne
en italie le gouvernement italien de
badauds lieu le maréchal anti-fasciste
signé un armistice avec les alliés à
syracuse le 3 septembre 1943
le 8 septembre on annonce la reddition
de l'italie
les alliés informe le gouvernement bat
do you qui vont débarquer au nord de
rome et qu'ils coopéreront avec les
troupes italiennes si elle attaque les
unités allemandes
au même moment le maréchal badoglio donc
très surpris de voir la 5ème armée
américaine
commandé par l'ue en général mark clark
débarquer dans l'abus de salerne au sud
de naples à plus de 250 km de rome
les américains et les britanniques se
rejoignent à eboli après la traversée du
détroit de messine par la viiie armée
britannique
le débarquement de la 5ème armée
américaine dans la baie de salerne et
l'occupation du port de tarente par les
britanniques
il est prévu que ces trois forces se
rejoignent immédiatement mais le
commandant en chef allemand le maréchal
kesselring voit les choses différemment
grâce à une défense intelligente ils
bloquent l'avancée des alliés et
arrêtent leur progression le long de la
côte italienne
le retard est telle qu'il faut attendre
le 20 septembre pour que les forces
britanniques et américaines arrivent à
se rejoindre près dé boli et ce après
des combats acharnés et de lourdes
pertes
la 5ème armée américaine remonte
l'italie
la 5ème armée américaine commandée par
le général clark commencent à remonter
en italie le 24 septembre 1943
cette campagne est un véritable périple
dans un terrain accidenté et boureux
face à une opposition allemande
déterminé à un moment donné trois
divisions américaines une brigade armées
sont prises en épingle dans un col
montagneux par trois petits bataillant
et nuit le maréchal kesselring donne
l'ordre de démolir les routes et les
ponts
ce qui retarde d'autant plus les
américains qui compte déjà en moi c'est
mes victimes parmi leurs troupes avant
d'arriver mais ils découvrent que la vie
n'est même pas défendu
l'armée soviétique libère smalls l'armée
rouge c'est renforcer massivement de que
l'opération barbarossa en été 1941
durant l'automne 43 elle ne possède pas
175 division d'infanterie mais 513 et
les brigades blindées se passait de 78 à
2 190
en seulement deux ans et demi l'armée
soviétique est devenu trop fois plus
puissante malgré des notes
jean bataille n'est pas étonnant que
l'offensive soviétique se passe bien
dans l'idée en automne le bassin du
d'olette est à portée de main et le 25
septembre la ville de smolensk libéré la
5ème armée américaine entre dans naples
alors que la 5ème armée américaine
commandée par le général clark poursuit
son périple vers le nord un journal
américain annoncent en gros titres
naples aujourd'hui rome demain il est
vrai que les forces du général clark en
affaiblir l'opposition allemande mais
personne ne peut prétendre que la
campagne d'italie n'est qu'une promenade
de santé
les principales défenses allemandes ont
reculé de 30 km et quand les américains
entrent dans la ville il y à peu de
résistance
néanmoins l'accès au fleuve volturno va
nécessiter d'âpres combats quand les
alliés prennent naples il est su de
lourdes pertes
7000 britannique et 5000 américains
meurent sont portés disparus ou sont
blessés
himmler inspectent les camps de
concentration heinrich himmler rejoint
le parti national socialiste en 1925 il
devient le chef des tout premiers essais
ce puits celui de la gestapo
comme il dirige les forces de police
allemande de 1936 à 1945 il est chargé
de l'extermination des juifs et de la
suppression de toute opposition au
régime
himmler prend le problème juif au
sérieux et travaillent avec ardeur pour
maintenir une efficacité maximum dans
les camps de la mort qu'il inspecte
régulièrement le chef de la gestapo est
capturé par l'armée britannique en avril
45 et doit être traduit en justice en
tant que criminels de guerre
mais il se suicide peu après son
arrestation
les troupes alliées établissent un front
entre le fleuve volturno et termoli en
italie le 7 octobre 43 la 5ème armée
américaine atteint le fleuve volturno au
nord de naples où s'est repliée le
maréchal kesselring pour y mettre en
place une nouvelle ligne de défense
le 12 octobre le commandant en chef de
la 5ème armée américaine le général mark
clark a établi avec les britanniques
une ligne très solides à travers la
péninsule italienne elle s'étend du
fleuve volta ono jusqu à termoli sur la
côte adriatique
les allemands et les alliés ne font pas
que s'affronter ils doivent également
faire face aux intempéries
normalement les pluies diluviennes
arrive début novembre dans la région les
en 1943 elle démarre un mois plus tôt
l'italie déclare la guerre à l'allemagne
on affirme que beaucoup d'italiens ont
été partenaires contre leur gré et de
l'allemagne
quand le premier ministre le général
pietro badauds nous présente sa
reddition a lieu les 8 septembre 43 la
majorité du pays un soutien
la reddition sans condition n'est qu'un
premier pas un mois plus tard mais très
octobre l'administration de bailleul ou
déclarent la guerre à l'allemagne
comme il n'avait prend aux alliés et au
peuple italien
au même moment le gouvernement italien
se réorganise sur des bases plus large
plus démocratique et plus en phase avec
son époque
les partisans yougoslaves se soulève
contre les allemands les partisans du
maréchal tito prennent le contrôle d'une
partie de la bosnie en 1942 et formé un
gouvernement provisoire
le conseil de libération nationale le
gouvernement des partisans étend ses
actions contre les allemands tout au
long de l'année 43
il réussit à former une armée de plus de
cent mille hommes qui va conquérir un
territoire de plus de cent mille
kilomètres carrés
20 43 les missions militaires
britanniques et américaines rejoignent
l'armée de libération
plus tard ils refuseront de reconnaître
l'autorité du gouvernement
le corsaire entre en action dans le
pacifique
le corsaire le chasseur bombardier
américain dans sa conception même n'est
pas prévu pour effectuer de longues
missions sa visibilité est faible et sa
boîte de vitesses se fragilise lors de
l'atterrissage
néanmoins ces problèmes une fois résolue
le corsaire sera d'une grande utilité
pour la royal navy ainsi que pour la
marraine
nikkei cet avion de chasse hors pair
excelle également lors des attaques
terrestres avec le grand manu l iccat le
corsaire permettent aux forces
américaines d'établir et de maintenir
leur supériorité sur les japonais dans
le pacifique à partir de 1944 et jusqu'à
la fin de la guerre
les marines débarque à bougainville les
offensives américaines dans les îles
salomon qui sont d'une grande importance
stratégique obligé japonais en 43
abandonné bougainville le 1er novembre
43 un débarquement américain permet de
sécuriser les ports de l'île et les
terrains d'aviation qui ont servi aux
opérations japonaises à guadalcanal
le débarquement dans la baie de
l'impératrice augusta contourne les
forces japonaises et sécurisé une tête
de pont importante
cela permet aux américains de construire
des aires d'atterrissage en moins de
deux jours
le 1er et le 7 novembre
les japonais tentent par deux fois deux
contre-attaqués et sont mis en échec
l'armée soviétique entre dans kiev après
avoir mis en déroute les allemands lors
de la bataille de koursk l'armée
soviétique avance rapidement sur le
front de l'est à la fin de l'année 43
début novembre
kiev la capitale ukrainienne est la
prochaine étape
deux ans auparavant les allemands ont
fait 600 mille prisonniers et
l'occupation a coûté la vie à au moins
200 mille civils
le 6 novembre les premières forces de
l'armée rouge entre dans la vie malgré
une forte opposition et se bat à chaque
coin de rue c'est inévitable
les allemands sont repoussés hors de la
ville au delà du fleuve mièvre
les tanks t 34 soviétique contre les
tigres allemand il faut savoir que les
premiers temps cayman ne sont pas très
puissant s'ils prennent le dessus c'est
grâce à leur déploiement audacieux
le puissant chars tigre arrive sur le
champ de bataille bien plus tard et sur
le front de l'est
il se retrouve face aux t34 soviétique
d'ailleurs c'est la supériorité buts et
34 devant les penseurs allemands qui
pousse les allemands à concevoir et à
fabriquer dans l'urgence le char tigres
mais le travail est bâclé
malgré sa puissance de feu il est
tellement massif qu'il devient difficile
à manoeuvrer et tombent souvent en panne
bien que le titre soit capable de
détruire n'importe quelle tant qu'allié
le t34 n'en reste pas moins le meilleur
des tanks la rff largue 350 bond de 2
tonnes sur berlin
l'armée de l'air américaine et la ras
lancent des raids contre l'allemagne
depuis la bataille d'angleterre en
automne 1940
tandis que les bombardiers américains
effectué des raids en plein jour contre
des cibles militaires spécifiques et
identifiable les raids de la rff ont
lieu la nuit surtout si les chasseurs ne
sont pas disponibles pour les escorter
le 18 novembre 43 les bombardiers de la
ra f ont pour cible berlin pas moins de
350 bond de 2 tonnes sont larguées sur
la capitale allemande
ce bombardement incessant durera
jusqu'en mai 45
la conférence du caire commence le
président franklin roosevelt le premier
ministre winston churchill et le
généralissime chiang kai shek se
rencontrer au caire entre le 22 et le 26
novembre 43 pour définir les objectifs
des alliés en ce qui concerne le japon
comme l'union soviétique n'est pas en
guerre avec le japon elle n'est pas
représentée à cette conférence
quelques jours plus tard le 1er décembre
le gouvernement américain produit une
déclaration signée par tous les
participants dans laquelle ils affirment
leur détermination de poursuivre la
guerre jusqu'à la reddition sans
condition du japon les signataires
déclarent que leur gouvernement ne
désire aucune conquêtes territoriales
les marines prennent part à hu
l'attak américaine sur l'atoll de tarawa
dans les îles gilberte est lancée le 20
novembre contre une défense japonaise
déterminer la petite île de béthio
devient le théâtre de la bataille la
plus acharnée de la guerre du pacifique
les marines se battent très souvent
contre un ennemi invisible car les
défenseurs japonais ont creusé des
tranchées et des tunnels fortifiés
de plus il semble déterminé à se battre
jusqu'au dernier
le 22 novembre japonais lance d'une
contre offensive
mais lille est sécurisé par le général
smith dès le lendemain seulement 17
japonais sont encore en vie
l'usiné de roulements à billes dans la
ruhr est bombardé le coeur industriel
allemand en particulier la vallée de la
ruhr est une cible évidente pour les
reds alliées en europe
le commandement des bombardiers
américains qui se trouvent en angleterre
lance une série de raids en plein jour
qui endommage gravement la production de
matériels militaires allemands l'attak
de l'usiné de roulements à bille dans la
ruhr 25 novembre 1943 en est un exemple
db 17 armés jusqu'aux dents avec ou sans
escorte de chasseurs vol en rangs serrés
et pénètre l'espace aérien allemand en
toute impunité
tout en mitraillant les messerschmitt
qui se font de plus en plus rares
les forces
soviétique avance sur un front élargi on
est le 3 décembre 1943 et depuis plus
d'un an l'armée rouge a pris l'avantagé
sur le front de l'est
elle progresse sur un front large et
rarement menacé non seulement l'hiver
russe a été éprouvant pour les allemands
mais maintenant ils ont devant eux une
armée plus entraînées et mieux commandés
et les renforts qu'ils obtiennent ne
sont composés que de jeunes recrues
inexpérimentés
la bataille de koursk à vide et l'armée
allemande de ses hommes et de son
matériel vital les tanks l'artillerie et
les avions
même si l'union soviétique a essuyé des
pertes similaires
elle n'a pas de difficulté à les
remplacer
rommel est nommé commandant en chef de
la forteresse européenne
il est évident pour le haut commandement
allemand que les alliés préparent un
débarquement sur la côte atlantique
européenne
cela fait déjà quelques temps qu hitler
a ordonné la construction d'un mur en
normandie
et cette barrière impressionnante est
sur le point d'être mise à l'épreuve
le 12 décembre 1943 le maréchal erwin
rommel est nommé commandant en chef des
forces allemandes postés sur les côtes
de la manche
le groupe armé b il s'occupe de la
forteresse européenne le nom donné au
mur de l'atlantique le renard du désert
n'est sûrement pas très enthousiaste
devant ses installations son concept de
la guerre est bien différent
les forces soviétiques attaque le
saillant de kiev tout le front russe de
smolensk à la mer noire évolué depuis
septembre 43 et la grande ville de kiev
est prise par l'armée rouge le 6
novembre
le saillant près de kiev tenus par les
allemands est créée par l'avancée rapide
des forces soviétiques aient pris
d'assaut le 26 décembre au moment où les
allemands doivent affronter un hiver
encore plus rude et plus terrifiant que
les deux précédents
vu les conditions il est difficile de
dire quel est le plus grand danger pour
les allemands s l'armée rouge où l'hiver
glacial
en tout cas le nombre de victimes
augmente de façon alarmante
les marines prennent le terrain
d'aviation du cac glossy star le jour de
noël 43 une flotte gigantesque remonte
les trois devis tias entre la papouasie
nouvelle guinée et la nouvelle bretagne
la première division de marines va
débarquer aux câblos oester à l'ouest de
la nouvelle bretagne
il faut sécuriser lille mais avant tout
il faut prendre le terrain d'aviation du
cap roosters dont se servent les
japonais pour lancer des raids et
bombardé la papouasie nouvelle guinée
les îles salomon et même l'australie
comme la plupart des territoires occupés
par les japonais dans le pacifique
cette position est âprement défendu mais
les marines sont mieux équipées et ils
investissent le terrain d'aviation le 29
décembre